yeah I feel like it's like spending
quality time with yourself when you're
taking selfies I know it's really nice
way to look at it I don't think selfies
are that annoying for me I've tried
sounds like I agree people demand more
self just get over here I keep trying
I keep trying to take them and like post
them because people you know we want
that and then I show my friends and like
is this good they're like that is awful
don't show your friends go to Milo's
Instagram all it is in Andrew I've been
it is him with different girls he has
you have more girlfriends than any later
kid I'm a theater kid that's like
hosting the view like for women of
difficulties around you at a table yeah
it's become a running joke on my
Instagram that you know I post all my
friends are girls it's just how it so I
post like with new girls all the time
and it's become a joke that everyone's
like oh my god is he dating this person
now and now whenever I post a photo I
just posted a photo of me at a party and
in the back there's a balloon and it's
like oh my god he's dating the balloon
[Music]
from Dancing with the Stars the movie
zombies teen sensation Milo Manheim
friend of the show I mean this is the
third appearance I know this is old hat
for you yeah for real I mean you were
yeah you're our other guest a good
friend of yours a good friend of mine
from Dancing with the Stars from
Instagram an entrepreneur in and of her
own right just such a strong cool woman
Alexis Wren is here too hi girl
thank you for being here I know Alexis
was there everyone's scrambling at
Sirius being like how did you get Alexis
right like oh can we can we figure out
like how did you book that bitch and my
friend that's how they talking to email
how did you book that bitch from the
president no but you're a huge get
obviously because you don't do a lot of
Simon I was like trying to look at other
stuff you you're I was scared to ask you
because I never want to ask my famous
friends to do something and make them
feel obligated to do it just as their
friends so I was very gentle about it
and then you were like sure in your
bubbly Alexis runway and then I was like
oh I'll book her on a day that Milo's
there so she'll feel comfortable because
they know each other they're friends
they are entrance oh my god each other I
was filming a package for dancing but I
appreciate you saying yes that you'd be
here but you would have not said yes had
you known it was 7:00 a.m. I thought
when you met Joe I thought you meant
like a show that like I go and sit down
dude are you joking me I was like I
thought about it and I was like oh no I
would have said yes like if I thought a
comedy show that you were gonna sit in
there my crowd for and oh my god and
then this is so different than what that
is and then I gave you I just kept
giving you outs because I just didn't
ever want you to just be here and not
what
here and you didn't take any of my outs
and I appreciate you being here because
and I appreciate all of you being and
this is I can't believe how stacked this
deck is today pretty good I it's this is
star power this is big-time let's just
was here she was here really early I
pulled in she was already there oh
really
she was there for like it does work it
works just like I like all right just
like a pen that's such a good idea I've
done it a bunch also makeup can not only
can work as pens but like blush can work
as eyeshadow can work as lip stuff and
they keep making up new stuff that we've
seen can be used everywhere
you don't know patooties are catching up
about Dancing with the Stars because
they went all the way they went to the
finals and throw really yeah they were
in the top four they both lost who was
work we lost together they lost more
tragic no they know we went down we went
down that's the thing is like I guess
there's a plate like everyone places I
didn't really know the placing I don't
care to know it doesn't matter it's all
you guys all all the top four one
because you got to dance the last dance
much screentime as you could have done
we did yeah I remember when we first met
we were at Good Morning America and I
was like wouldn't it be cool if we made
it to the finals together we did it
honestly I'm gonna say this right now I
don't think I've ever told you this but
when we are a Good Morning America the
first time I've said this on the show
before what I want you to hear it when I
met you I knew you just following her
and following just so you know I
unfollowed her rolling
that he could be backstage would be like
I had been following her for like what
three years or something I know and you
liked also I tagged you in a photo of
mine like two years ago as a joke
because I was getting myself is you knew
who he was and knew that he had like one
follows follows each other that a mine
is like there's a dude that trolls me
lately that's uh that's like almost
naked you know like he's got his
six-pack I'll show you the photo he does
it every single day
he unfollow zan files and then likes a
bunch of pictures and then probably
unlike some and likes him again I think
Alexis if every guy who put that much
effort to get your attention on
Instagram you had to have well I just
I'll send my DMS your way yeah please
I love it I could actually collect them
from someone girlfriends of mine I send
my friend Allie I make her send me all
the like filthy nasty that dudes DM
her because I just keep him I think
there's so much fun yeah some of the
are like some guy was like I would
I want you to fart in my mouth
they're trying to get your attention
they really see her and read her energy
and know that that's exactly what she
wants here trying to get your attention
I feel like a lot of these DMS they know
that maybe you're bored and you're gonna
go through the requests you know what I
mean and they need to stand out some
ways so they say I want to do something
like that for sure they'll make like
group chats big energy like group chats
and it'll just be like five guys trying
to like get my attention everyone
collectively were ten inches cold us all
together I mean there's so many I'm on
group people our group DMing me about
you and they all have Milo
they all have versions of your name in
their name and their handles Milo's
pants Milo's I everything Milo's shirt
Milo's Loubs I know that weird so
Whitney as has always been like touching
my earlobes since like we met and like
that was like the thing exactly post
about on my story all the time and then
there was a bunch of earlobe accounts
that they literally if I post a picture
with like a water bottle it'll be like
Milo's water bottle understand you know
what they would do to get that water
bottle man like they would do love I
used to be one of these girls and when
you're obsessed with a guy and you're
coming of age and you're having all
these feelings about boys that you don't
even understand and it's like lust it is
like it's this intended it's an energy
and you feel like I will have him if we
meet we will date and I'll understand
that feeling that the fan the standing
obsession of this guy that like you feel
like you know and you're obsessed with
every little thing do you remember your
first crush like your first first real
like its star celebrity crush no like a
crush that was attainable my science
class was I mean who was your first
crush do you remember oh my god so I was
home-schooled and so in my home like
it's just proximity okay so you were
homeschooled no wait my entire life
never been in a classroom what yeah
weird right
I had my lo bring her to school today
but I do want to come to your graduation
oh you're totally I'm definitely I'm
just gonna stand outside from the
outside hey guys how is it fun sir we're
arresting you I want that
seventeen-year-old boy
[Music]
you